we've looked at different clients of
induction right and even though
induction is the same every time test
the suit proof Tessa suit protesters to
improve the prove the deductive logic it
looks different based on what category
of result you've got so we started with
series because Wheaton you a lot of
those results already what you were
proving was an AP or GP you can access
you can prove those results by other
mechanisms we didn't need induction but
it very quickly went past aps and gps
like the question we just did you can
come up with any kind of combination of
things being added up so long as you're
in integer layers and induction will
handle this after she Ruiz when they
looked our products oh so before we get
to that next one if you've got any
things together but multiply again if
you have a product that's expanding into
an expanded and it's still an integer
then you got the first part of her
second part a third part then induction
will eat that for breakfast too after
that wing with the divisibility and the
reason why divisibility fits is because
you've got multiples and they leave it
digitally right now there are two
categories here that I've gotten down
which I've alluded to but we haven't we
actually haven't done any questions so
far they are GOG so for example whatever
ones i sent you actually have met some
of the geometry questions in your
exercise a classic one is the angle some
above n-sided polygon right that's
easily proved by induction and the last
one that i also voted we have done is a
proof involving calculus so for example
we have shown we proved it last year
that the derivative X to the M is add X
to the N minus 1 right and we can prove
that through first principles and then
some fancy by verbal expansions and so
on but if you start from this guy right
if you begin with you and then you
posture you make conjecture and then you
do this option to the proof because you
can use
this and you can treat these guys as
integers you can prove this lawyer then
there are other ways of extending it to
the other real numbers okay so if you
want to you can do that now what I've
left off is what is generally I mean
what universally but most people regard
as the hardest category of induction
proof and that's the inequalities okay
no inequalities bench brave a little bit
because the logic of an inequality is
very very different to the logic of an
equation and all these guys despite how
different they are they are all working
with this equals there okay and now we
kind of enter differently so I'm going
to go through this question with you I
think it's from one of the exercises
that I scared to you I don't leave us
see it an agency but variance of award
exist here's the result we were okay
yeah I we're gonna have you go this I
will tell you right from the outset i'm
going to show you two ways i'm doing
okay and they're both very kind of okay
i'm not let you settle in your mind and
if I expect every kind of 50 50 which
way you prefer which method you buy but
it's really important that even if you
settle on what he liked this one's cool
you must master both because sometimes
you'll only be able to do this one
orderly be feasible with this way and
other times you want the other method up
your sleeve okay it's not like it's not
as hot as it goes on the dog it's equal
to a larger than Joe like I'm just
saying this question is really
I would say to New York yes I would say
no I didn't think it's as obvious as
what I don't know maybe I'm unless it I
can you know what sorry everyone I know
I'm lesser mathematician than a lot of
the people in this room it's just that
I've got an extra 12 years up on you but
I look at that and I don't think it's
obvious unless I so can't be one but
it's too there's obviously going to be
lied to them like so so basically what
you're doing this is actually a proof by
induction that's exactly what you're
doing okay so let's set this out okay
the two proofs that i'm going to show
you right inductions always test is to
improve Tessa to improve okay the test
is always going to be the same like
there's no oh how which way shall i try
to test it so that's going to be the
same but when we do the assumption in
the proof it's going to bifurcate like
this okay so let's begin with the common
step let's start with a test for the
first allowable value which is too okay
so usually I start with the left hand
side I do stuff with it for reasons that
will become clear about two minutes I'm
actually gonna start with the right hand
side what is the right hand side equal
to before n equals 2 well as I mentioned
before you don't take any shortcuts on
the first line you substitute it in
directly 7 squared of course is 49 plus
25 so it looks like i'm getting 74 okay
so i have a number for the right hand
side let's have a go at the left the
left hand side is just 12 square which
is 144 now at this point was I try to
demonstrate I was trying to get to that
inequality right and this number this
144 is greater than the right hand side
so i can say that now is bigger okay now
you might see why i started with the
right hand side because this lets me
conclude with a line that has the left
on the left and the right on the brian
you can switch it around if you want but
then you have to switch need equality as
well and my little simple brain gets
confused so if you start on the right
you'll end up with the line that looks
nice and it just follows that pattern
okay now let me just point out going
from the second last line on the board
to the last line this is the first thing
that makes inequalities different to
acquaintances right when i said this
right hand side this number is 74 this
number 74 that's because 144 is clearly
bigger than done when you're dealing
with inequalities we're going to sort of
face in and out of equations and
inequalities so long as we sort of obey
what's bigger than what okay so this is
the first thing I want you to point out
that's very very different from
equations for equations everything's got
to stay the same if that's what
equations means right the inequalities
little more fluid so let's move on now